[MUSIC PLAYING]
JEFF JOHNSON: Welcome
back, developers.
Jeff here, and I'm joined
once again by our friend Alpha
from Pivotal.
Alpha is here to
tell us about how
to handle monitoring and
logging to our Cloud Foundry
applications.
Last time we were
together, we talked
about how to monitor
our infrastructure,
but now we're talking
about the Foundry.
What's next, Alpha?
ALPHA CHEN: The next step is
connecting the Cloud Foundry
logging and metrics pipeline,
also called Loggregator,
to Stackdriver.
JEFF JOHNSON: So
this would be data
ranging from running application
logs to health metrics
such as container CPU usage.
ALPHA CHEN: That's right, Jeff.
Loggregator is
designed to hook up
to external data sinks, which
Cloud Foundry calls nozzles.
The Stackdriver nozzle
connects to the pipeline
through UDP today, potentially
switching to TCP in the future,
and receives a
[INAUDIBLE] stream
of data from Cloud Foundry to
prevent backups in the system.
The nozzle can be
scaled horizontally
as necessary to handle
increased log traffic.
JEFF JOHNSON: That's why
we, and I mean a great team
from Pivotal and
Google, including us,
developed the
Stackdriver nozzle.
This open-source project
connects the Loggregator
to Stackdriver
logging and metrics.
It is available on GitHub as
part of our Stackdriver tools
BOSH release.
Alpha, can you show us how to
get set up with the nozzle?
ALPHA CHEN: Let's do it.
First, we need to enroll our
GCP project and the Stackdriver
metrics API, and
ensure our quotes are
set to the appropriate limits
as documented on our GitHub.
Deploying the nozzle can be done
by modifying the BOSH release
or deploying the tile through
PCF Operations Manager.
JEFF JOHNSON: Let's use
the BOSH release for this.
ALPHA CHEN: Sounds good.
To deploy the Stackdriver
nozzle, first upload the latest
release from our GitHub
repo to our BOSH director,
and then add the
release to the manifest.
Now create a pool of nozzles
with some light configuration
to connect to Loggregator
in our BOSH manifest.
JEFF JOHNSON: This
sounds like a great time
for, and here's one
I prepared earlier.
ALPHA CHEN: Let's
paste it in for now.
We'll have a more detailed
example in our GitHub linked
in the description below.
Let's also run the world's
fastest BOSH deploy.
JEFF JOHNSON: Voila!
So, we've got logging.
Let's prove it.
Logs generated by
our application
are streamed into the
Stackdriver logging console.
You can see the logs appear in
near real-time as they happen.
The logs we generated show
up with detailed metadata
related to the GC instance and
the Cloud Foundry application.
One great use of this
is to filter down
to logs from a
specific application.
Streaming logs can be
useful, but often, you
want to perform aggregations
and analysis on your data.
This can be done in real-time
by creating a log sync
from Stackdriver into BigQuery.
ALPHA CHEN: Every
message that CF generates
maintains a structure which
we can use in our analysis.
Let's see what unique
user agents have
hit our Cloud Foundry today.
JEFF JOHNSON: Sure.
Let me test my minimal
BigQuery knowledge.
So we want to filter by
HTTP start stop events.
And I'm going to add a
simple GROUP BY statement.
OK, just find it down here.
Here's that structure
we talked about.
And I'll just go ahead
and select that value,
so we can see it.
And there you go.
There's a list of
all the user agents
that hit our foundry today.
ALPHA CHEN: That's awesome!
So now we have a
full logging pipeline
backed by CF, that Stackdriver,
and Google BigQuery.
So let's take a look
at those metrics
we've been talking about.
Why don't we open up
Stackdriver monitoring
and take a look at our
user-created dashboard?
JEFF JOHNSON: This is
another cooking show moment,
but the creation
process was just
Add Chart, click, click, click.
So we'll just go
ahead and skip it.
ALPHA CHEN: CF exposes
a ton of metrics
on the health of your Cloud
Foundry and applications.
The Stackdriver nozzle
handles these metrics
and sends them into
Stackdriver monitoring.
This dashboard goes beyond what
we can measure at the VM level
and gives us a look into
the huge number of metrics
that Cloud Foundry
exposes on each container.
JEFF JOHNSON: Cool.
So we can see information like
CPU activity of an application.
And we can do that at the space,
org, or even application level.
ALPHA CHEN: This sort of view
lets operators and developers
better understand
their applications
and make scaling decisions.
The user can also create
alerts to detect abnormalities.
JEFF JOHNSON: And that's
application monitoring
with Cloud Foundry
and Stackdriver.
ALPHA CHEN: And thanks for
watching our series on Cloud
Foundry and Stackdriver.
JEFF JOHNSON: For more
information about Stackdriver,
and Cloud Foundry, and
Google Cloud Platform,
check out the description.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Check out our last video on host
monitoring with Stackdriver,
and be sure to check out our
playlists for more videos
on Pivotal Cloud Foundry.
Don't forget to subscribe.